welcome to this video against quattro
princesses i'm probably mispronouncing
that but what is meaning for Prince
princesses princesses are kind of kind
of a weird one Prince one princess for
princesses sounds kind of weird okay so
we got the green felt and I'm playing
the Bishop f4 a three-line I have a
negative score against the sky one out
of three ja this is one of the one of
the lines there night if form as
possible now but a bit questionable d
takes e4 is the most reliable line now
castles I think Quincy Quincy five
losses straight away to 295 p.m. so he
avoided that now queen sofia this novel
yeah I'm ahead on the clock that doesn't
happen often but I only recently studied
the slide a bit me not to to be a yeah
not in a huge detail but good enough I
think um so Queen age 50 hmm that's a
rare line they normally go Quinn a five
okay let's start with that move
preventing any Bishop g-form so maybe
Queenie 24 possible eform be 45 would be
nice to get in quite often black reacts
with 94 himself him nope not this time
so if all right that looks very logical
'if I've is retreating or what problem
probably has to be a night we ate and
now hmm 94 looks good for 93
and this good you might have night to
deform and Queen f5 is also possible hmm
like to try to use this this is awkward
queen position 95 is also interesting
maybe this is a good idea putting this
on a safe square maybe I should have
gone to age 22 have Nigeria still okay
my idea was 95 but he just has prevented
that hmm he should have gone to h 2 i'd
watch most much better really much
better
I'm just bad that was just bad Bishop h2
was much stronger okay skidding bishop
be six now in 69 Teague's yeah I totally
lost any advantage there that goes it
was bad just bad okay
395 next unless he takes with the f port
which looks kind of weird but you never
know why you never know some 95 m just
centralizing the night so Knight f6 wins
the exchange Jack let's do that yes he
has a bit of compensation with possible
94 mph but it's not really going to
happen quickly if he goes 94 I can take
it and the queen is hanging some
problematic um so Quincy form or where's
the Queen going there they go nie Dage
form Queen have six background can also
go here that's not bad attacking you
five
and Queenie forms in the position trying
to trade Queens slightly down 40 seconds
time boys
hmm seems to have taken back a little
bit did I blunder something and he's
laughing laughing at me or something I
don't know I don't see something great
you can go 94th I'm going to take a
flick when you form trading stuff okay
i don't get it i just take this it's the
central pawn if I can take it I well I
always have Queenie for him and in some
nah not here some cases knight c6 I want
to say it's not really happening yeah
come on simple simple chairs setting
sides on f7 so he basically has to trade
so that that should be a win time
warning
fetting rookie seven hear that that's
the easiest way to kill any counter play
for winning rook endgame checking him
first and then rupees seven was even
better actually but doesn't doesn't
matter that much okay so just take f7
him check be4 is the symbol hmm doesn't
help much orillia i can also just do
this just take this additional porn
check
I still stuck on the eat ranka for Luke
c6 rook c8 and some have those reasons
yeah I didn't really didn't play the
opening well I mean okay I'm okay I
think I'm really fine here and now I
really should have a great position 94
is the computer says I'm winning just
winning him so why exactly let's figure
that out ok I understand that I'm
threatening 93 winning so Queen here
this is I saw that move and I didn't
really see what to do here but the
computer is just saying Bishop g5 wins
but why why does this win Jeremy okay a
93 is still a big threat quite clearly
his queen is in trouble and he doesn't
really have a milk yeah if he does that
I can take yourself and I'm winning the
exchange oh that's true and this g4 Wow
wow yeah that's computer chess for you
and white wins so I could have one with
94 m I mean it looks very fishy blacks
position but I really couldn't believe
that this kind of thing is working okay
this is a very lame move of course in
comparison this is also better yeah just
to have this idea at least in the mix
but the worst is definitely over now for
him like here here yea TX takes Queen B
5 was a move that are also considered
and like by the comp but this shouldn't
be bad oh it is bad then I g5 is good
now let's let's move I did not consider
a tall strong though I cannot take it
and you threatening neither three yeah
Black is fine him chanting like this
yeah here I have to fight for equality
not sure with how much stones of success
that's bad and after this he blundered
texture change instead yeah not the
highest quality game ever but
interesting am really interesting how
good bites position is there when I play
nitey form it looks like the right move
but I didn't see anything against this I
didn't think I didn't see a Bishop g5
him I only thought that ok I can go back
and now I wasn't it wrong clear to me
what I've gained them maybe I still
should have done that I mean I saw this
line I didn't see Bishop g5 this is
still better than what I had in the game
yeah ok thanks for watching